[Musica]
Cominciamo con un respiro Anzi due
inspiriamo
e speriamo
l'oceano produce 50 per cento
dell'ossigeno presente sul pianeta Chi
di voi ha mai sentito questa frase
Ma
vi siete mai chiesti che cosa veramente
voglia dire
l'oceano produce 50 per cento
dell'ossigeno che respiriamo Oppure
possiamo dire che metà dell'ossigeno che
respiriamo il prodotto dal mare ma chi
nel mare produce questo ossigeno l'acqua
gli animali che ci vivono dentro le
piante Esistono le piante Marine
esistono forse delle foreste subacquee
Beh andiamo a scoprirlo insieme ieri
sono andata al mare al molo Dove vado
sempre a raccogliere un campione d'acqua
è molto semplice basta passare con un
retino sulla superficie dell'acqua in
una forma 8 per raccogliere tutto quello
che sta sulla superficie il retino
chiaramente è sottile non è come quello
per pescare i pesci poi lo viene messo
sotto un microscopio e non ho potuto
portare il microscopio ma lo possiamo
vedere insieme
Eccoli sono proprio loro Questi
microscopici organismi verdi che si
chiamano fitoplancton
fito piante
planton erranti vagabondi ma non
facciamo subito arrabbiare Gli
scienziati e gli scienziati non sono
veramente delle piante sono piuttosto
alghe o batteri
pianta alga Sono due cose ben distinte
ma torniamo ai nostri microorganismi
Come fanno a produrre l'ossigeno che
respiriamo Beh proprio come le piante
assorbono energia solare aggiungono
anidride carbonica e acqua e producono
zucchero o energia che poi viene usata
per i loro processi metabolici come
scarto producono ossigeno che è quello
che usiamo nella nostra respirazione ma
non scordiamoci che anche loro sono
degli esseri viventi e anche loro devono
respirare
Adesso vorrei veramente presentarvi li
abbiamo intravisti questi organismi che
li ho fatti un po' vedere abbiamo capito
come funziona la produzione di ossigeno
ma vorrei veramente farveli vedere
farveli conoscere qui c'è il campione
numero uno per la produzione di ossigeno
il microrganismo fotosintetico più
piccolo del mondo
0.5 Micron
0.005 mm potete immaginare così piccolo
Eppure produce 20 per cento
dell'ossigeno presente nell'atmosfera
Pazzesco Tra l'altro sono proprio loro
questi piccoli organismi che hanno
inventato l'ossigeno
2450 milioni di anni fa
una evoluzione una veramente una
rivoluzione direi la grande
ossigenazione
praticamente hanno reso possibile la
vita come la conosciamo oggi ma al
momento è stata una catastrofe tutti gli
organismi che vivevano lì non
conoscevano l'ossigeno non sapevano
usarlo e quindi sono morti soffocati
nell'ossigeno assurdo
Beh ma torniamo ai nostri organismi
vorrei presentarvi degli altri
personaggi
secondi non per importanza sono i
gioielli del mare le diatomee le
diatomee sono delle bellissime
scatolette dorate fatte di due valve o
due conchiglie che si incastrano sono
fatte di vetro silicia e sono bellissime
producono molto dell'ossigeno che
respiriamo ma non solo una volta morte
invece che degradarsi la loro conchiglia
finisce sulla fondale del mare e va a
formare il sedimento E formo una sorta
di polvere dorata questa polvere dorata
o di atomite o Terra di tomacea è usata
anche per la nostra salute viene usata
come integratore alimentare o viene
usata anche come fertilizzante naturale
secondo o terzo come personaggio sono i
Dino flagellati Dino non come dinosauro
Ma come vortice E flagellati perché
flagella due flagella due codine una
intorno al corpo come cintura che gli
permette di roteare e l'altra proprio
come una codina dietro che gli permette
di propellersi in avanti
Ricordiamoci però che stiamo parlando di
plancton plancton sono tutti quegli
organismi che pur muovendosi non
riescono a contrastare la corrente del
mare quindi sì i movimenti in avanti Ma
relativo
tra i più famosi forse ne conoscete
anche qualcuno c'è la noctiluca
scintillens Forse avete avuto la fortuna
di mettere la mano in mano in mare la
notte E vederlo brilluccicare come un
tappeto stellato
poi ci sono lexusantelle quelle
microscopiche alghe che vivono in
simbiosi con i coralli li danno il
colore meraviglioso che vediamo nelle
barriere coralline le danno l'ossigeno e
lo zucchero
ultimi personaggi non perché sono finiti
Ma perché non posso presentarveli tutti
sono i Coco litofori chiamiamoli cocco
così non ti sbagliamo questi piccole
palline da basket rinforzate fatte di
placche di carbonato di calcio che non
solo producono l'ossigeno ma con le loro
placche fanno anche da riflettore per i
raggi solari aumentando l'effetto Albedo
del mare cosa vuol dire che invece che
assorbire il calore del sole Lo
riflettono indietro Quindi mitigando il
cambiamento climatico riscaldamento
globale
anche loro una volta una volta morti
finiscono sul fondale marino e vanno a
formare il sedimento E questo sedimento
negli anni ha costruito le bianche
scogliere del Nord Come La Scogliera di
Dover
questi piccoletti sono microscopici non
li possiamo quasi mai vedere ma quando
si riproducono in maniera spropositata
quando fanno quello che si chiama un
Bloom
i Cocorito fori diventano fino a 90 per
cento della massa fitoplantonica
Praticamente ci sono solo loro e quindi
li vediamo anche dallo spazio
Questo è un Bloom una fioritura algale
Praticamente come se in un prato tutti i
fiori sbocciassero lo stesso momento
cosa succede che ci sono delle
condizioni ottimali Allora non sono solo
cocco a farlo Ok anche dinoflagellati
anche le diatomee succede che ci sono
delle condizioni ottimali per cui C'è
abbastanza luce ci sono abbastanza
nutrienti poi ognuno Chiaramente ha dei
gusti diversi però di base luce e
nutrienti cosa succede si riproducono in
massa si riproducono tanto a diventare
uno strato superficiale in cui ci sono
solo loro fantastico cibo per tutti i
pesci tutti gli erbivori però non solo
perché riproducendosi così tanto anche
loro
che devono respirare quindi Anche loro
usano ossigeno e anche loro producono
anidride carbonica quindi si crea una
sorta di tappeto di cibo soffocante non
molto bello crea anche dei danni
nell'equilibrio della popolazione e
quindi dei pesci
in più questi queste alghe per farsi
spazio danno come delle gomitate alle
altre alghe quindi producendo delle
tossine
queste tossine non sono solo dannose per
le altre alghe Ma i numeri così grandi
sono dannosi anche per i pesci e anche
per noi ma non fraintendetemi il Bloom
non è un problema in sé il Bloom fa
parte del disequilibrio naturale per
mantenere un equilibrio sembra che un
controsenso ma vi assicuro che non lo è
è una sorta di predatore Ok piccoli
predatori che hanno un effetto sui più
sugli altri pesci
quando Però chiaramente diventa
pericoloso si chiama henfold Bloom Red
tight E allora lì sì che può causare dei
danni ai pesci può fare delle zone di si
chiamano Dead zone dove tutto muore ma
quelli che creano un danno che aumentano
questo disequilibrio siamo noi con le
nostre azioni che non per forza sono sul
mare possono anche essere in campagna
Infatti quando usiamo fertilizzanti o
pesticidi
che finiscono nei fiumi poi arrivano al
mare e al mare aumentano i nutrienti e
siccome con il riscaldamento climatico
c'è anche più caldo c'è anche più luce i
Bloom sono diventati sempre più
frequenti e intensi
Quindi con le nostre azioni anche
lontane abbiamo un impatto grandissimo E
aumentiamo il disequilibrio naturale
togliendoci però cibo e ossigeno a noi
stessi
Quindi qua non si tratta di proteggere
la natura Ma si tratta di salvaguardare
noi stessi
noi esseri umani abbiamo bisogno di
550 litri di ossigeno al giorno Questa è
una media molto vaga Nel senso che
questo è la quantità di ossigeno di cui
abbiamo bisogno Quando siamo a riposo
ognuno di noi fa diverse cose durante la
giornata non tutti dormiamo tutto il
giorno quindi l'ossigeno è molto di più
chi ci dà questo ossigeno Beh abbiamo
visto che metà di questo ossigeno ce lo
danno il fitoplancton insieme
chiaramente alle alghe e alle piante
Marine Sì perché esistono anche le
piante marine
ma in un mondo che sta cambiando in un
mare che sta cambiando cambia anche
l'ossigeno Beh sì
cambia l'ossigeno e ce n'è di meno nel
senso che il mare si riscalda e contiene
meno ossigeno e assorbe anche meno
anidride carbonica in un mare più caldo
diventa anche un mare più acido e i
nostri personaggi come i Cocorito fuori
che hanno bisogno di costruire una
placca di carbonato di calcio fanno
molta fatica e non solo loro
quindi vediamo come subito le nostre
azioni hanno un impatto
determinante per quanto piccole sono
ecosistema molto fragile ma non perdiamo
le speranze non possiamo deprimerci
all'inizio di questa serata di questa
giornata
è il momento di agire di agire come
singoli ma di agire come gruppo di
prendere delle posizioni e delle
decisioni anche difficili a volte ma che
siano mirate a un futuro che ormai è
presente dove non ci manchi il fiato
per esempio
potremmo Piantare una balena
perché le balene sono le più grandi
contenitrici di anidride carbonica sono
queste bestie enormi In più la loro
cacca è il fertilizzante perfetto per il
fitoplant Grazie
[Applauso]